everyone welcome we are back we are now
here at continued so at the Women in
Technology summit and we are now sitting
down with Nehru cosa thanks for joining
us thank you for having me really
appreciate having and we will be talking
about the ck-12 foundation what you're
building right now how is impacting
people this is really exciting and let's
go ahead and start talking about it so
teachers about what it is and we'll ask
you some questions so ck-12 is a
non-profit foundation and its mission is
to bring access and reduce cost that's
how we first started happy to tell you
my story a little bit to kind of build a
background on that yes so when I came to
this country I joined I got a degree in
molecular biology and I became a mother
biologist and I did some research on I
was doing research on cancer genes DNA
and its expression and working with
radioactivity and all kind of you know
siting tools that came out of me
eighties
but I became pregnant with my first
child and at that point I gave up my
career because it was radioactivity or
pregnancy so I decided to give that up
and I continued to have three more kids
so I have four kids and the further
thing that I busy mom busy you know but
I also had to figure out what I was
going to do for my kids and since I had
the time and the inclination so I went
out and found the best school which is
child centric which was about the
children learning by doing
yes they had no textbooks they had you
know a library which was the center of
the universe and the kids weren't there
that picked out their own you know
figured out their information and kind
of nerve like that so as they went
through I became more fascinated and I
spent a lot of time in the classroom you
soon started asking questions how kids
learn and you know what are the things
that get in the way hard as a teacher I
teach so many kids in the classroom so
from there when I kids finished and went
on to high school at 50 years old I went
back to school to get another degree in
education to find out what the issues
were it was there that I found out cost
was an issue one size fits content in
the form of a textbook which she
couldn't customize was an issue and not
being able to teach can see the
different abilities at the same time in
a classroom were those kind of things
that you know I said okay why can't we
then do a technology solution and so at
that point I found myself for a
co-founder who was a technologist had
been funded by kleiner perkins he done
three companies for them and he just
finished his last one and I kind of
roped him in and said let's do this and
I had never run a company but it was my
passion that I was so passionate about
but I knew we someone had to do this so
today after 11 years we have a
technology we have the content that goes
in the technology most ethical companies
are actually providing just the
technology and so for me doing secret 12
was actually you know a way to kind of
give back and what we did was to give
everything for free but you can
customize everything and we can stand at
the line because it's foundational its
broad eight to twelve to be used all
over the world and so that's how secret
twelve came around is interesting
hearing your story about how when you
were going through molecular biology
that the pregnancy happened and then it
was almost a first of all I wonder if
there's a way to help support women that
want to pursue careers at the same time
that they want to support the children
and then also then it kind of led you to
ending up being with the C key to
initiate otherwise he might have worked
on cancer genes not a very long time so
now that this opened up it's been about
10 years right see kids over 11 years so
now so so the one of the things that you
mentioned was you started analyzing
education and seeing what are the
limiting factors for children to be
fulfilled through all of the knowledge
that they can actually get in the
foundational specifically and the
biggest one you said was cost okay so in
the u.s. something in the u.s. okay
so interesting so then now I want to
know kind of what are the what are the
other limiting factors in other places
in the world and how are they different
well to some extent you know
government-run a lot of education in
different countries and the subsidized
and their subsidize ation I mean I went
to the President of India at that time
dr. Kamal Haasan and as I was talking to
him I said you know I'd like to do this
project and then here that was 1993 and
he looked at me
do you realize that it costs pennies for
us to give books to the students in
English there's no way that you know we
are paying the same kind of money you
guys are to the publishers it's some
business right so as a result of that I
think the cost is much higher in the
European country or the Western
countries versus other from other
countries the cost isn't that much of an
issue but I think what you get is a lot
of you know you get just some text to
learn from in those countries they don't
have the luxury of having access to the
newer technologies that come along like
with you know computers you can give a
video you can give an interactive you
can get feedback and right time
otherwise these children are sitting
there waiting for their exams to be
given back to them the results and you
know they've lost that moment where
they've been agonizing over did I do
that question right you lose that
thought so there's you know a lot of so
there is a cost in those countries as
well not so much of the cost of the tech
the content but in terms of the cost of
not learning something oh yes yes you
know not getting that feedback in time
and that's a huge cost in the USA as
well as rest of the world and that
something technology really helps with
so our system can give you feedback
immediately and then also show you what
you did wrong so if you think about that
and say versus when you get the exam
back back and then you see that my Mart
got this question wrong well you don't
remember the struggle don't remember the
struggle yes and then also then the
setting up time with the teacher
afterwards to learn about it and yeah
versus continuty you know yes that
moment of aha
I see what I did wrong because now you
cannot go back to that struggle you have
not every child you've been wiped it out
of the memory human brain is like that
that is probably the coolest thing that
I've learned so far
yes that was very interesting so the
moment of when this is maybe a good
example of how to relate this is by when
we are learning directly from a parent
or directly from a boss or a co-worker
inventor
and when we're learning directly from
them we get a continuation of the
education so when we do something like
imagine if I was paraphrasing what you
said but then you waited two days tell
me what I would that I was wrong with
our paraphrase and imagine you know
imagine learning one thing we know about
learning is that it's additive it just
doesn't happen you know by itself you
have to keep immersing I mean immersing
yourself and learning okay one step two
step three step four step yes and then
suddenly the picture becomes at some
point for different kids the picture
becomes clearer as they learn more and
more and more so imagine a young kid a
child right born they learn to kind of
lift their heads they kind of get up and
they start learning how to walk right it
doesn't happen overnight it happens in
in kind of continuation as a muscle
memory kind of keeps doing something
over and over again you want to turn
around you hear sound you hear colors I
mean you see colors your baby tries to
kind of you know and and basically it's
what the body does over time similarly
the brain does the same thing I mean you
start learning you know there are only
one to nine numbers so you start adding
one to nine and units and then suddenly
you say oh well if I add nine and four
that's more than nine now where does
that what happens to that so then you
learn about tens
then you learn about hundreds and you
learn about thousand you know and so on
that you know so all these things
happened I mean unfortunately the system
has kind of come up with these thirteen
years of learning K to twelve are
officially because you have different
kids going at different rates to learn
and did we get the are moment faster or
slower than others and yet you know we
kind of keep them in this okay so
because I can tell that we're about to
get into a little bit of the
personalization and the dab of
technology that you've built and I want
where we're gonna get there I want to
keep us for one more moment yeah on the
additive learning and the continuum
because I think that is so interesting
continuity so with the additive and the
continued continuty it's as though when
we not only when we get the paper back
that we have a grade on it are we then
we we're already breaking the continuity
because we had to wait a couple days to
get the paper back but also then is the
additive learning there as and do we
take what the next moment of the
educational process is and do we seize
it and go and get excited about it and
go and pursue it so it depends on
individual child there's some children
who will continue the hunger to do that
there are others who will be like you
know okay so what's the big deal
right it depends on what kind of
background they're coming from what kind
of mindset they have and so you know in
that that seems like a very important
time to interject to say that the parent
is actually such a vital role an adult
an adult and that's but but is for
almost everybody on the plane most
people it's it's specifically the parent
of the parents responsibility if you
birth the child into the world it is
it's for foremost your responsibility
and the communities together but but
you're specifically is to inspire the
child with all the different
opportunity that's available for them to
a salute Lee right okay it is the
parents responsibility but let's be
honest okay there are parents in this
world who cannot do this for whatever
reason right you could say they come
from a place of not being able to help
the child they can come from they don't
know what to do with their child they
don't you know it probably didn't go
through the formal situation system
themselves my father for example was the
first in his generation and his family
ever to go and do a degree in math okay
he didn't have any role models so how
are we supposed to now he was driven but
how is every child supposed to do that
because probably if the parents are you
know kind of struggling to make ends
meet so I don't want to put the blame on
on the parents and not give them that
kind of you know responsibility but
let's think about this if there is a
teacher and I've seen teacher that's
what kind of fascinated me and got me
drop me into education I saw the best
teacher who knew every child in her
classroom there aren't that many of them
she knew exactly she would keep folders
on each child what they knew what they
were you know how to excite them how to
make something happen for them so a lot
of it was project-based a lot of it was
passion based and give them a purpose in
life right that's a tall thing to do for
every child yes and you can't put that
on the parents all the time yes I think
if you're in a position you oratory
every child to do that if you're going
to bring a child in but at some point if
a parent can do it society needs to step
in me because we're in all this together
yeah so if you're going to have a school
system we need to find the best way to
make sure a child can learn and you know
what we keep saying change
mindset changing mindset is the hardest
thing to do yes it's so hard difficult
to do there are you know there's a whole
push you know this whole movement about
mindset I'm a big believer of mindset
but rush to change people from where
they are to where you want them to be
it's very difficult so let's let's let's
work our way in into into the adaptive
learning by saying this so we have both
the the parent takes lots of
responsibility for the child so does the
community that teachers around the child
to provide lots of opportunity for the
child to actualize into that what you
what you've built enables more
continuity so that the child when
they're when they're using your platform
are able to get instant feedback about
what the what they're learning and how
they're learning it and you you've
created
I would love to learn more about the
algorithms that provide the adaptive
side of the learning process so the
continuities there now how is it adapted
because we have friends that are working
on with like Adam gazelle II and the
neuro scape the and Achille interactive
these these different labs that are
working on video games that can do
things like help kids with ADHD help
them focus help you with higher working
memory these types of things so we're
interested in what the adaptive tech is
how it yeah so it's it's a not a simple
system okay it's it has a lot of
information being put into it so there
are two things there's the content
itself and there's the technology itself
so as far as the content goes we've
created a continuum of the content in
math and science we've actually also now
interrelated the math and science so
that we have connections how you know
you know they might connect and I'll
speak to that a little bit later
but we have the content that's passed
and the concepts it's passed into what
are the skills and you know how it's how
much time they spent did they agreed the
day how much time they took to do the
code you know the actual the each
content has practice attached to it that
we can tell how much they know so it's
an adaptive practice so if it's too hard
for you it'll go easy you know it's hard
if it's too Ichi easy it'll go hard for
you the ability to create content in a
continuum way knowing the knowledge
pathways and like I was telling you
about units and tens and hundreds and
thousands you know the ability to be
able to create those connections and
these connections are very complex
they're not easy right because they
could be coming from any rich way and so
we have taken time to create those and
we are constantly improving those
algorithms that you know it goes into
the into a black box as you might say
over lag algorithms and so that content
and the technology that we build along
with it starts putting out you know what
the students knows what the student
doesn't know what the teacher needs to
know to help their students so we've
kind of put created this whole system
around this learning and if you use it
continuously from you know they want to
move next to next to next year after
year I I think it's a teacher helper or
a parent helper Yeah right
so it's taking away it's taking away the
wait time for the students so they don't
have forget about what they learned or
what they didn't do right in the moment
we can tell them and we can say we can
recommend to them way you know what they
might want to refresh that they might
have missed so you could have been you
know insect two years back you could
have missed something and you don't
remember it you can say hey can you go
back and really review that
and come back and so we don't never want
to discourage kids and say no you're
you're you did you're failing or you're
whatever we want to be very supportive
for the students to one of them and so
if you're a shy kid or you're behind you
shouldn't have a you know feel bad about
yourself
and we want to be able to get you where
you need to be does that help
yes I liked how you described the
complexity of the content and there is
very complex and then also how it can be
it's hot in more novel and easy to
understand ways and continuous ways in
adaptive ways too easy we go harder to
hard we go easier until you gain a
momentum yes and you pick things up and
these different strategies that you're
implementing they've been they kind of
been lost because we went from in many
cases we've went from a single teacher
to a couple dozen students and like you
said each student is different yes each
student and this is this is partly with
the advent of artificial intelligence
and robotics into our world that it
becomes a personal learning agent that
helps the student yeah tailored and
customized to them to their learning
abilities and styles but there is this
sort of foundational knowledge that
needs to be learned and then the some of
the shots such as language very
important to be able to communicate
science math history and then and then
from there art music that kind of
continued humanity built humanities
building up and and then having so then
so then when does the child like about
this is this is interesting to ask at
about what time at age 12 or where does
the child start to be able to
personalize what they're learning
little bit more towards their interests
see that's an excellent question
excellent so the when when mean when I
envisioned this system we were thinking
about everyone being able to customize
their own right teacher customizing a
parent customizing or even a child
customizing when you think about
learning at this level this foundational
learning it's hard for a child to know
what I have to learn next right they
don't know they don't know that there
are tens and there are hundreds and
there are thousands of little millions
right they don't know that they don't
know in in science they don't know the
complexity you know when you're teaching
these kids physics and chemistry and all
are taught in the very abstract fashion
an abstraction for a child is is very
hard to get to they start out very
concrete yeah so if the Sirat can't
concrete they're not going to be able to
say how you know there's a critical
thinking creative thinking this you know
those levels are higher level thinking
so similarly what we have to do with
them is kind of hold their hand till one
day they say oh wait a second this is
what's missing from them but that stage
is very different for each child some
people some children don't even get
there even in college so I don't know
how the brain works enough I don't think
we all know how the brain works enough I
mean I keep looking for these things I
will do a lot of literature surgeon this
stuff but there isn't anything that says
you know how are we gonna you know how
are we gonna know that the child is
there to move on to deciding themselves
in general when you get to college you
should supposed to be able to do that
but I'm not sure everyone gets there
I wonder if there's a if there's
something about the maybe speed at which
can be calculated of the students
progress in a specific subject that can
indicate their understanding and their
interest past just making the content
harder for them but also being like hey
there's these three branches of math now
that will just offer to you and then you
know or do any of these sound
interesting a little one to sentence
summary of each one of them and how
they're applicable let's say in the real
world and then they can maybe that maybe
that's happening at the age of 12
maybe it's happening earlier as well
when maybe they go down a rabbit hole in
in them in the mathematics and the
certain aspect of it that gets them to
really go get very excited about logic
and something like that yeah so I think
unless you teach students hold their
hands and take them that path which is
not what's done in the school the public
school system doesn't do that so they
have very standards they have an exams
to pass most of the teachers are
actually teaching them based on those
exams because they're you know kind of
they themselves are judged by how the
students do on the standardized exam and
so as a result of real learning is lost
so with ck-12 from very early on we have
the theory that we are going to teach
you from so if you look at what we call
simulations we kind of take the stand
that we are going to talk about say how
does a plane stay of flow training and
so repeatable examples yeah real-world
applications of that and so if you start
talking to them about trust thrust and
you talk about free diagram free you
know energy diagram they lost but what
if you were to able be able to relate
this with this question and think about
what are the sub components of this
question
and then be able to show them and let
them play with it very often if these
are taught as to the variables
themselves that's right so we do that
good chemistry we do that with physics
right now I'd love to create you know
I'd love to create some partnership to
do that but biology and finish all these
and kind of we might have some ideas for
you yes I'd love to do that because you
know we can only go at the we're only 30
people in palo alto and then another you
know 15 20 people in India yet we're
doing all this ourselves and so and
teachers are submitting content as a
contractor to you and then those are
those are mostly written things this
other stuff we do ourselves video the
the assimilations and the ability to
interact with the stuff the adaptive
system the intelligent system was a eyes
yes all that we're doing in-house by
ourselves and the teachers of submitting
text learning yes they're doing the
actual content on you know the like the
Flex book which is a customizable
textbook yes so they are doing that part
of it and so we created about 250 flex
books for all k12 today we have over
200,000 flex books customized by
teachers and schools in districts and
they're all free there so another good
thing about all this you know
customization is not just
personalization but the ability to hold
institutional memory in one place like
the teacher I was talking about earlier
now foundation kind of does something
yeah work as well yeah right so she
passed away but all the memory she had
about stuff went with her right
so it's institutions every year can
figure out what worked today this year
and you iterate on it next year that
you're constantly improving by learning
learn by doing yeah right so that's the
that's the power of the system that's
the power of technology technology by
itself is just just a tool it's like a
hammer I mean a hammer and a nail and
melt and until there's a human being
doing something with it it's of no value
so one thing that we did from the
beginning was not only just create the
technology we actually create the
payload to go with it and so that you
know isn't what's not what most EdTech
companies are doing they they are
looking for content because they didn't
build it and so you know we are where we
are it's so inspirational hearing about
the work that 45 people are doing to
both make all these flex books as well
as all the teachers that are helping
make the flex books and this huge memory
bank now love of content that is now
able to be accessed from around the
world for free yes huge and then then on
top of that also making the simulations
that then students can go and
experientially tweak variables and be
able to see how things change I very
vividly remember in middle school
playing with a bridge simulator and that
was so fun for me because I remember
messing with you know the math physics
the architecture and actually seeing how
stress testing windows lighter car a
happier car yes yes and so that and the
you know it was green and then when it
went yellow and red then it you would
break and and so these types of and with
planes what this is how we better
understand our world it was just like a
bobsled how does the bobsled keep on its
track you know I try to convince my
developers to let it crash but they were
upset they said we can't let it crash
what have some students you know param
gets upset I said ah anyways next next
level next version of that would be a
crash but but you know you're right I
mean there's so many things that we do a
bow and arrow
or you know sound or you think about you
know how does snow melt yeah
so for chemistry we actually go into the
atomic structure of snow we zoom into it
so they can understand how salts have
any sprinkle salt on snow in the
mountains or on the streets how that
interacts with the water structure
frozen structure to release the energy
or you know just those kind of we've got
finished the physics simulations but we
have to do the chemistry you've done
half the chemistry we have to do the
other half by the by the end of
hopefully by the end of the Sears we'll
be able to finish those it takes time to
really envision those and create them
but then twenty million people from
around the world last year yes used
yes ek twelve yes and then how many of
them were active monthly you know I
don't remember that number but it's not
as great as that because most people
just want to download they don't really
understand that we have all this so we
haven't done a good job we don't
advertise too much because we're a
non-profit and this stigma of non profit
and free means that it can't equality it
can be you know this great stuff but you
know I think we have above average I'm
sorry I don't know no worries
there's out of the twenty million people
that are using is is there a good
percentage of them in the United States
versus most of them up from the United
States over five thirty five cent
percent in the u.s. because they have
assets that's so like over 5 million ish
people are in from other places around
the world that is really so interesting
let's see when those simulations get
translated into Portuguese into the
onion and the Chinese into Hindi into
German that's what's happening that you
know will get more and more so have a
plane simulation which other
kind of we've got like hundred and
something simulations that are on site
you should go take a look-see k12 org
ck-12 dot org yes yes and then I'm so
excited to go and play around to
simulations and also send them around
and link will be in the bio of course
for everybody to check out oh my gosh we
could just chat for so long about
education and the importance of these
fundamental pieces of knowledge for
parents to help inspire 4c k12 help
inspire community to help inspire and
the importance of that you know we're
witty right now women in tech
international at the summit what can we
do specifically to maximize the
potential of young
um I think what I believe first of all I
don't differentiate the kingdom in girls
and words mm-hmm
I think it's an issue yes yes I think
it's a really important message to give
all children this is not about your
gender this is not about color this is
not about anything other than you as a
human being you can learn anything you
want so I would encourage hey stop being
I'm a girl or I can you know don't be
afraid just go do it and we should
support them as much as we've had which
means we should support them in the real
world not separate them from boys or
gonna separate them for some you know I
I don't believe in that separation I
think you know early on when we were
raising our kids we put computers on the
floor even when they were born and then
when they started crawling they would go
and you know kind of play around with
them it didn't matter so we you know
we've before fortunately for us you know
we're in a we were in a different
position but I think all of us can take
those kind of steps where we don't
differentiate that you're a girl or a
boy it takes time to get that into the
head when the generation that's kind of
frozen right now it's harder to change
their mindset versus the next generation
that's coming on so I highly recommend
that all adults all women go and mental
in the plant in the local classrooms go
and say look I am a scientist look I am
whatever I am
you know you can do it too so this is
going to take a little bit of time but I
think we should be able to mentor
everyone needs me that's what we heard
at MIT Witte that's all most women are
in need mentorship yes so do children
I like your firm
ferm you are about food and the
importance of that once we start
differentiating breaking people up let's
just call it all human and look all
equal opportunity to access all these
different technologies for education and
for inspiration and for actualization
for each human for each child when
they're born into the world to align
with that yeah I I actually can I say
something about that I worry about you
know this the generations of say excuse
me but I don't know how to say it so I'm
gonna say it the white boy syndrome
mm-hm we are are we're creating an
unintended consequence of say raising
others by pulling something down hmm
right this is what the previous
generations did they push the minorities
to stay ahead now we want to push those
and pull them down and bring up this I
think there's got to be some other way
to kind of keep all people kind of
moving ahead and not putting pulling
someone down to the others can rise
that's what we have to find that
equilibrium so that we can actually not
do unintended consequences
yeah I just I just saw a post that was
why can't women hate men I was like wait
a second there's a great a second like
can we just figure out how to all be as
humans together because you just made it
very clear like there was definitely
pushing people down to go up but now by
pushing these down to go up or not any
better
yes so you know for me I think it would
be great if you know we kind of say okay
we'll headed how do we all make forward
movement yes thank you and you know
there's so much stuff to be done even
these systems we're talking about
they're not perfect we just started out
on that yeah
oh my gosh the internet just started
talking like yes yeah in terms of the
length of evolution and exactly and here
we are pressing our fingers on two
computers and without any real hard
looks at how it's affecting our
psychology or human interaction yeah
without any hard looks at structure for
advertising and the way that companies
revenue but you took a very hard look at
education and I want to just quickly
make sure that you address this because
the general data privacy rights things
becoming a bigger deal now so students
that are under the age of 13 need a
parent consent against the platform
right but besides the dole previously as
a non-profit we didn't have to worry
about that and I'm gonna when you think
about this right a child under 13 comes
to see k12 and I'm going to say to that
child I'm sorry you can't learn anything
until your plane gives you permission
Yeah right I mean the irony of that it
tells me yeah especially if the parent
passengers there's some sort of a
struggle and the relationship between
the kid and the parent they pay the kid
almost can't act as a sovereign
individual before the age of 13 I want
to know how a plane flies Yeah right
yeah sorry you know you're under 13 you
can do better they need to sign off yes
and then what if the parent says that I
don't want you to learn how to do that
yeah - it almost adds a layer of
complexity but it also it adds a layer
of security at the same time so it's
kind of hard - well you know I think
what's what's I always ask when ok
Google and Facebook I completely
understand that that you don't want your
kids to be on it all the time and
whatever who are they being exposed to
but it's a place like sea control yeah
yeah right where are you going to
practice no you can't practice
oh so it's almost like general data
privacy right should be a little bit
more tailored to individual sites
because on Facebook it totally makes
sense versus on ck-12 right it's so
ridiculous that you want a child who in
a moment
as this curiosity and wants to learn
something goes on a site under 13 and
there's a no you can't enter yeah yeah
you can't satisfy your curiosity oh my
gosh nuru oh wow this is so fascinating
we could talk for so long about this do
I want to ask you a couple quick
rapid-fire questions on the way out how
about we ask about how do we kind of
balance the we are one mentality with
the importance of geopolitical
leadership that's that's the problem
right I mean when you think about even
in the u.s. today you know I don't
really want to get into the political
realm because it's so hard to solve that
mm-hmm I think we we ourselves are I
think education should be separated from
political I think it's a shame that kids
don't have access and because of
political reasons I mean you get funding
and then get funding cut back and we you
know whatever and you know if you think
about divorce and she's funding charter
schools that are religious or you know
all these complexity I want to stay
focused and pure so this is vive your
nonprofit we don't care about all that
we are going to give you foundational
information and learning tools that will
help you lose but I don't want to get
caught up in any of that political stuff
it's such a difficult question to answer
it is I really pressed
ask leaders around the world this
question okay how about our now what do
you think about the although everybody
in terms of socioeconomic status is
slowly coming up nevermind slowly coming
up exponential technology is causing a
very very sharp increase for the very
wealthy right now
what do we do about the lower middle
class you know it that's that's a really
tough situation because if you think
about it human beings power is not
something that you know as long as the
markets are free and as long as you're
free to do whatever whoever has the
dominant position that's its currency or
whether it's technology or whether it's
brains to create stuff there's always
going to be these you know people who
have an advantage because they know how
to gain the system and think about
what's happening what happened in the
financial situation Bernie Madoff and
all those scams I actually have no idea
how we gonna solve those because as long
as human beings have differences there
going to be differences you know I don't
know how to take care of that it's going
to be a really different people will
tell you they know the answers but I
think they don't know they're nobody can
know this answer this is why we ask it
because people give very interesting
solutions to the problem that are part
of the full solution and then maybe we
can glue together some of the pieces for
a pretty good one but you said as long
as there is the the differences it's
very difficult to find something maybe
if the overall basic needs of the
hierarchy were filled to a point where
we were all just then able to focus on
purpose
or focus on meaning then then at that
point at least because then there still
needs to be some room for innovation and
creativity for people to have an
incentive for it this is this
complication then there's the
globalization complication to the wealth
and equality conversation and now we're
talking about what's like the most
naughty throw and artificial general
intelligence and this well when you
think about this okay when the internet
came along the idea was to give access
to everyone equal access that's why it
was free right when you think about it
like that
people started you know you got lot of
you just user-generated content I can't
even remember the last number of
websites created by people I think it
was in the billions or something I might
be completely wrong I don't remember it
is very high very high like that right
but how many of those actually get any
people right so when you think about it
which sites I mean think about Google
and Amazon and Apple and Facebook and so
again the people that kind of have the
knowledge the wherewithal and the
ability to gain that system in whatever
way behavioral economics and you know
all that so the ones that kind of are
the first movers and that tend to get
the uptick and so again when we try to
kind of democracy democratize something
it doesn't work because it can't be that
everyone has equal quality yeah equal
outcome yeah yeah so so then it is like
the it's like the global conversation
around the people that have the most
power is needs to happen and we need to
figure out how to have that conversation
okay well you know if you come across
this solution remember to send it to me
I will spend a whole lifetime
I'm trying to inspire people to have the
conversation and we probably will come
close to figuring out a part of the
solution only this is why one of the
good things about companies is that they
usually only have ten years lifespan or
something like that so there's a limited
life span so new generations can keep
coming up similarly it's it's about
renewal all the time so other people can
get a chance at least from you know from
royalty you know from the prince and the
kings and all that it's changed which
were four generations we actually still
say saying with you know the queen of a
union I mean Elizabeth and her family
that model is slowly disappearing you
know so now uncommon person can actually
drives up so things are changing it's
just that it's a constant flux and so
new ideas will keep coming up yeah
that's the only change that'll actually
in the end give everyone a chance yeah
and I love the millennial generation Gen
Z generation because they're just so
they're thinking in such different ways
and they have access to technology in
such different ways okay couple last
thoughts is what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world oh my god
my children my dogs my husband I hope
and nature and that you know I jumped
out of a plane one time and when I
jumped up I did too
oh my god then the chute opened then it
was on the leader role just yes yes and
you realize what a beautiful thing we
have whitewater rafting I've done this
you know yes so actually immersing
ourselves in the experiences that awaken
us to the beauty okay how about do you
think we're alone in the cosmos I hope
not
yeah it'll be more interesting to have
other people there you know Deborah
Fischer and all have been looking at you
know this whole thing and they they're
finding stuff she's a astrophysicist and
they're finding me know they're finding
stuff so I hope we find other will be
interesting and I hope they're friendly
yeah all right yeah yeah I want to be
wiped out if you see Marvel agents of
Marvel not yet okay well you've got to
see that I'm a big ma book you know
coming from you know DC fans yes I love
all those things yeah and do you think
we're in a simulation I don't know about
that
I'll let you know once I go to the other
side of it check it out yes yes yes your
wow what a pleasure thank you
exceptional conversation thank you for
joining us thank you on the show this
has been so fun we've learned so much
from you really really so cool about the
continuity of the experience of
Education rather than getting the test
back two days later but you're right
there to get an immediate feedback
adaptive feedback and then have
simulations where you can test the
different variables yourself as a child
across the world translated a different
language
maybe we can make some connections for
you in the biology space yeah we would
love to do that so I will do that right
when we finish a conversation everyone
thank you so much for tuning in if you
guys had a good time make sure to
subscribe comment below with your
thoughts we'd love to make sure go
create with this so if you enjoyed the
content go talk to other people about it
make a video about it yourself go write
about it yourself maybe start something
in the field submit some content to
ck-12 yourself also join us we need to
continue going around beautiful
organizations like women and tech summit
so we need your help on patreon to help
us scale and help us continue going and
interviewing very smart people and
communicating their content to you
throughout the world so join us there
thank you everyone for tuning in and
we'll see you soon thank you
you